- [Reporter] Lisa Marie
Presley's, daughter
actress Riley Keough is set
to become the sole trustee
of her late mother's estate.
That means Riley will effectively be
in charge of her grandfather,
Elvis Presley's legacy.
That decision resolves a legal dispute
between Riley and her
grandmother, Priscilla Presley
six months after Lisa Marie's death at 54.
But how did it get to this point
and what does Lisa Marie leave behind?
Lisa Marie was the sole
remaining heir of Elvis Presley.
- When Elvis died.
The estate was valued at
only $5 million, you know
$25 million in today's dollars.
- [Reporter] His ex-wife, Priscilla
stepped in to try and save the estate.
That involved opening Graceland
to the public in 1982.
- [Katherine] So essentially,
the property became instead
of a drain on the estate with maintenance
became a money maker for the family.
- [Reporter] Elvis Presley
Enterprises was also set up
to manage the estate's assets.
Lisa Marie took over the estate
and Elvis Presley Enterprises in 1993.
- It's estimated that by the
time Lisa Marie turned 25
and fully inherited the estate
it was valued at around a
hundred million dollars.
- [Reporter] That turnaround
would not last long.
In 2005, Lisa Marie sold the majority
of Elvis Presley Enterprises,
but retained ownership
of the Graceland Mansion.
The sale was to help
clear $20 million in debt.
According to a 2018 lawsuit filed
by her former business manager.
- She accused him of letting
the estate dwindle away
and he in turn, counter sued accusing her
of living an extravagant lifestyle
against all better advice.
So we know that money was
being spent in big quantities.
- [Reporter] Details were
laid out in court documents
filed last November related
to her divorce from her fourth husband.
They revealed Lisa Marie
was spending an excess
of $92,000 per month
that included expenses
for her young twin daughters.
She received around $104,000
per month on average
from EPE, and took home a
monthly salary of $4,361.
As an employee of Graceland
she had around $95,000 in the bank
and nearly $715,000 in stocks,
bonds, and other assets.
But she owed $1.8 million in taxes.
Overall, the filings
indicate Lisa Marie Presley's
net worth was negative $3.8 million
in the months before her death.
Lisa Marie's assets were held
in what's called a living revocable trust
with her three surviving
children as beneficiaries.
But here was where things got complicated.
- In 2010, she named her mother, Priscilla
and former business manager,
Barry Siegel as Crow trustees.
Priscilla Presley says she
discovered this document
purporting to remove
Priscilla and Barry and in
place appoint Lisa Marie's
daughter Riley Keough
as a trustee.
- [Reporter] Priscilla said
the signatures didn't match.
Names were misspelled
and various trust rules weren't followed.
So Priscilla asked a
judge to declare the new
document to be invalid
and to keep her position
as co-trustee to oversee
her daughter's assets.
In June, Riley Keough asked
an LA Court to approve
a settlement that will see
her become the sole trustee
of Lisa Marie's assets.
Those include the Graceland mansion
and the proceeds from a
life insurance policy.
The settlement also included
an undisclosed one-off payment
to Priscilla, who will
also be paid a monthly fee
As a special advisor to
the trust, a spokesperson
for Priscilla didn't respond
to a request for comment.
Immediately after the
settlement was reached in May
Priscilla said she was pleased
to resolve the situation.
Riley's lawyer didn't respond
to multiple requests for comment.
The legal dispute played out
as the Elvis brand expands
to new audiences and revenue streams.
The King of Rock and
Roll's legacy will endure
under a unified front for now.